[Musik]
freunde der sonne
heute habe ich einen besonderen gast bei
mir das ist lisa und lisa ist deutsch
experten
wir kennen uns eigentlich schon wie
machen damit zusammen dass nachhilfe
format musste wissen dann macht man
chemie und ich mach deutsch und heute
schauen wir uns an was sprache mit
unserem gehirn macht und aus aktuellem
anlass auf mit welchen sprachlichen
tricks politiker uns beeinflussen
ok gerade als naturwissenschaftler denkt
man sich gerne sprache bla bla bla bla
fachbegriffe sind ja schön und gut aber
jeder weiß echte wissenschaft macht mal
nur mit zahlen das natürlich quatsch
beziehungsweise es ist naiv zu glauben
dass man den großteil der menschen mit
trockenen zahlen überzeugen kann ich
kann da nur auf unser video zu den
sehgenuss verweisen was menschen viel
mehr beeinflusst wenn auch viel subtiler
ist sprache das fängt schon an wenn wir
babys sind also dann wenn wir noch gar
keine sprache verstehen außer eben
sprache ja wie ich ging da kennt ihr
doch oder unerträglich hohe stimme
melodischer singsang absurde gesten
diese baby oder amtssprache ist im
grunde überall auf der welt gleich aber
es geht eigentlich gar nicht um die
worte sondern um die art und weise wie
das ganze übermittelt wird diese
babysprache dient zur sozialen bindung
aber mehr noch ohne diese übertriebene
emotional aufgeladene sprache würden wir
als kinder die sprache erst gar nicht
erlernen glauben manche linguisten
bemühen unser leben lang sprachlos
bleiben
ich hätte ich gehe ich durch hier machen
christus sprache ist also viel mehr als
nur wörter das merkt man vor allem dann
wenn wörter keine konkrete sondern
symbolische bedeutung bekommen weiß
metaphern zum beispiel metaphern sind
bildhafte sprach ausdrücke wo wörter
oder begriffe aus ihrem eigentlichen
zusammenhang in einen anderen sinn
bereich übertragen werden beispiel für
eine metapher jemandem das herz brechen
ich meine natürlich kann man jetzt nicht
brechen man könnte es zerstechen
products r drücken oder in den bars
anderes beispiel jemandem das wasser
reichen
ich weiß einfach nicht ob mark der
richtige für mich ist das duo ich glaube
wir können ihn nicht das wasser reichen
oder den nagel auf den kopf treffen
du hast den nagel auf den kopf getroffen
und jetzt das unglaubliche linguisten
und neurologen haben herausgefunden dass
unser gehirn auf metaphern also auf
übertragene bedeutung anders reagiert
als oft wörtlich gemeint ist man steckte
probanten in ein mrt also eine art hier
in scanner und beobachtete welche
gehirnregionen bei bestimmten setzen
aktiv werden zb sie beißen ein apfel
oder sie beißt ins gras bei setzen mit
übertragener bedeutung wurde nicht nur
der präfrontale kortex aktiv also der
teil
die fans der für komplexe bedeutungs
verarbeitung zuständig ist sondern auch
der motor kortex der für bewegen von
armen und beinen zuständig ist also kann
man sagen metaphern bewegen uns
übertragen und buchstäblich aber das ist
noch nicht alles habt ihr euch schon mal
gefragt warum ein abweisender mensch
kalt ist und ein liebevoller mensch war
neurowissenschaftler erklären dass damit
dass zwischenmenschliche interaktion die
seelen gehirnregionen aktivieren wie
physische erlebnisse zb das empfinden
von wärme oder kälte nach dieser theorie
sind metaphern nicht willkürlich oder
gesellschaftliche konstrukte sondern sie
haben ihre wurzeln im gehirn so erklärt
sich dann auch die metapher gebrochenes
herz bei liebeskummer und auch bei
sozialer ausgrenzung deren dieselben
gehirnregionen aktiviert die bei
physischen schmerzen
deswegen ist der vergleich zwischen
einem gebrochenen bein und einem
gebrochenen herzen eigentlich nur
logisch der linguist george lakoff sagt
dazu wir reden nicht in metaphern wir
denken im mit ok wir reden also wie wir
denken dass das erst mal ein einige
forscher gehen aber noch einen schritt
weiter die behaupten dass die sprache
und denken beeinflusst wer von euch
könnt ihr jetzt gerade spontan nach
norden zeigen
also ich jetzt nicht mehr norden wird
immer noch nie weiter der pfeil newerth
im april schließt zum beispiel
gebrauchen in ihrer sprache keine
relativen raum angaben rechts und links
sondern himmelsrichtungen in folge
stellt es in emmerich ziemlich leicht
sich nach den himmelsrichtungen zu
orientieren
während bei uns manche schwierigkeiten
damit haben google maps zu folgen oder
wenn wir denken wie wir sprechen dann
kann man behaupten dass die deutschen
viel schaden freudiger sind als zum
beispiel die amerikaner im englischen
gibt es nämlich gar kein wort für
schadenfreude
manche benutzen da einfach das deutsche
vor schadenfreude klar es ist nicht so
dass man keine schadenfreude empfinden
kann wenn man kein wort dafür hat aber
wissenschaftler sind sich einig dass
sprache unser denken in gewisse bahnen
lenken und jetzt kommen wir zum
interessanten teil in sprache unser
denken beeinflusst wie kann man sie
nutzen um andere zu überzeugen oder zu
manipulieren wie setzen politikersprache
ein um uns zu gewinnen das erfahrt ihr
in teil 2 den gibt es bei dieser kanal
link dazu in der
infoguard und in der video beschreibung
und gleichende in karts schon freude
entwickelt 123
du musst schon mit sagen so schlau wenn
ihr uns kitzeln wollt klickt ihr hilfe
deutsch dafür sind schlau und hier
unmöglich nicht dass nämlich anfangs